our gay Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge and again I only mention
that he's gay because it's the only
reason he got the job he goes on CNBC
and the host just was not having his
nonsense look really tone-depth I mean
what you're telling me so just stick to
the script the economy is great the
border is secure our cities are safe no
one's pretending to just be honest
wouldn't it be better to just be honest
with the American people about the soup
that we're in right now and and we can
all try to deal with it together instead
of just nobody's saying that our
nobody's saying we don't have any
problems but if you don't pause and
recognize the meaning of one of the most
significant pieces of legislation so far
in the 21st century just because we also
have a lot of other problems then I
think you're really feeding into a
narrative that's that's uh you know
pulling America down when he's pushed
down well no one's saying there aren't
any problems but there are massive
problems and we all know it and it's
because of all of the nonsensical
policies that you people have pushed in